back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
my my rap name yeah Oh probably yeah
Oh young rabies look young rabies yeah
young rabies little thick yellow boy
babies look thick in the house
you heard the Jerky Boys will be the
jerk boys what's up bro oh yeah [ __ ]
jerk boys yeah you be the details back
like jerk jerk jerk jerk jerk jerk
chicken the boy chicken the boys didn't
the boys ahh this is my favorite moving
the club dude climbing the smallest vine
in the world alright that Peter pumpkin
and then I hit it with I hate it with
the little thick just finish it off a
couple buttons Oh cross buns they call
them over here bro do you should get a
tattoo of like some like a refrigerator
there's nutrition facts on my arm of a
footlong subway lost and 40,000 calories
jeez dude good to see you today man no
keep touch me man you're looking a
little swaggy swaggy dawg yeah this
thing is really coming along this look
like a real a lot lizard subway up in
here this hot hole right there they got
you don't touch gang someone busted a
bunch of honey on the walls
oh gee and check out the culture corner
coming in there you guys a cultural
culture up hoes down jeez up Doug don't
touch yeah we're gonna Japanese gang
dude on where'd you do your shirt still
has the lines on it from the box
oh my bad yes brand-new there got a lot
of starch in him
little big lot of starch in that -
what's wrong why don't we start a band
dude I don't think and young raise young
babies and you only wear ray-bans oh man
they give you disease yeah
free bands annoying it's the flu dude I
got ray bands like no it's rabies dude
just rabies dog yeah you gotta tighten
the squad up yeah man it's a very
authentic looking so mr. Rogers is fire
right now I'm waiting for it to come out
Tom Hanks Oh Tommy Tommy Hanks it's
already out friends call him Tommy no
Jobson Christmas bro dude I'm a deal
read general no you're talking about mr.
Rogers the movie drops win in December
bro with Tom Hanks oh he's wearing oh
it's already is dedicated to him bro is
it watch your words do cuz he runs
Hollywood brought you want to work in
this industry yeah I better bow down to
the Hanks come on you know hey dude you
know his sons a white rapper oh yeah
well a lot of those men's if the man is
real good his son is real not good yes
I'm real not good at life
well there's a lot of that detour dude
it's a lot to deal when your dad's
Forrest Gump you know you look like a
fiber Aryan that's like [ __ ] what are
you talking about to do what every week
what are you talking about this you look
like boobs and butt sacks this is a cost
system jacket man that [ __ ] a custom
green jacket it is not customs yeah you
made grilled cheese for Miley Cyrus well
she's a freak huh who know who's dude I
know I know I know oh when I see one I
know you think I wear this sweater well
know who's a freak bro bro in that
straight-up DMV starter jacket
that look like something he stole from
some dude who was in his coffin
I can senior citizen cape to do look
like [ __ ] look at gonna rob a bank with
a toy is looking all your money the red
line you're on your lizard
your mom got catfished by now there's a
lot of names a lot - ready bro you know
you're gonna have you know you're gonna
have um tri-polar disease II have three
[ __ ] first names no last name okay
what's so distracted is chin right now
dude I kept my [ __ ] Harvey Oswald oh
my dude a cuza is in the house
gesundheit
bro whatever you just said she is this
Chin's effort to get a date choices for
gender I'd maybe you do your chinder Wow
my sidekick is a new bridge in how's
that black suburban yeah two minutes bro
preferences no talking he looks like an
uber driver for a kebab crane bro can
you stay into a kid home to see the full
thing well the real chin please stand up
chin shady and I hope you get a date bro
dang that jacket is if it doesn't work
out get a job at the morgue no he looks
like the ghost of penguins passed Grove
that's what you look like
did you check out that area
that Wow vanilla rice trouble in will
Encino no Jen I'm just joking man you
look absolutely wonderful you're looking
don't matter candidate yeah not this
thick card catalog Jackie over here
Britney looks like looking some old
woman who gave birth to did the Dewey
Decimal System how I smile at jcpenney
bro what are you talking about they said
there's a superhero jacket this was in
the Ironman area what do you mean you
don't think so look at it I don't think
so yeah I don't think you look at it
your therapist therapist emailed me said
she's worried about you
she said you keep saying again bullied
by imaginary friends do you know they
could email me too bro
sweet confidential brain thoughts man
try to connect with me man focus on your
client here later duty let's do
something where we burn your sweater and
all of our grandparents come back to
life you know my grandpa coming back on
my grandma you don't smoke grandma Monet
male that smoke dude we all start
jumping in pause it ain't good man I'll
be pissed the way the world is now dude
I don't say the N word bro less you do
you feel I'm just joking man
unbelievable chair gym is just that
earring is so swaggy
I'm surprised I held up how you got here
on your ninja or you look like a Maitre
D' do you like [ __ ] every in funeral
bro you start in the next Tokyo Drift
[ __ ] Calabasas drift over there it's
so you know a great man you look like ya
look like your dad earring is so sick do
I have some children very nice man do I
think we're get a lot of applicants we
already got some man dude we got yeah we
got a lot of
submissions sorry Chan nobody submitted
doc not one not one not one nothing no
no not not even troubling no dudes no no
transsexuals nothing one black woman
said after seeing the cut down of chin
saying that he isn't interested in black
women said it's okay we don't want him
anyways
oh forgot that one Maddie she's pretty
good-looking and you're lost Jen Missy I
was trying to help him out - yeah let's
go through all of them you sure just
went I like all types racism will cost
your brother dude - one right now - one
I feel like we got a we got to post it
though like really post about it and
create like an old graphic I can't
believe that chin I would eat I would
take you out man I would take you out
yeah not dress like that but ya know I
would taking my dress like that would
you
yeah I would definitely man where would
you take him I'd probably take him to
some country that has issues with the
Koreans and see and tell him he's a
pinata I would take him to the other
Korean north or south and be like Oh got
you guys this pinata sorry oh it's a
chin yatta somebody did sit in the song
for chinder
oh they did oh yeah
young rabies a little thick boy thick in
the house y'all
this is Chan Ho Ching can sing huh
ginseng is it's going down unknown
gender do that's how I sing bro where
are you going with it
you don't make this racial dude easy man
as a nice song did you not enjoy [ __ ]
was sick
oh who rose got it dude how much
emphysema sit your prick is right it was
even more like the Black Plague using
the old school baby
sounds like smoke it sounds like secret
do you look like mr. bro you look like
blister Rogers mr. Rogers
[Laughter]
Duncan sticks kid even one of those
doughnuts dicks
he always had swaggy kicks on there
always clean and took them off who mr.
Rogers yeah yeah beautiful man damn
speaking of beautiful Ching came with
that heat today dude that hot huh that
thoughts sob about to come out bro butt
chin dressed like that dude you're
asking you're asking for trouble you can
get a bunch of strippers looking for for
the light bills to be paid and [ __ ] if
you don't get a bunch of Russian uber
drivers that want to fight yeah you try
and take over their territory bro you're
not Valley cheese that's like
some of the air like that if you don't
have a [ __ ] switchblade get out of
here bro you got one I knew it hell yeah
do you have throwing stars noe does he
has one throwing star I [ __ ] knew it
do you stuff do this you're gonna miss
it the first one nobody gets the first
one right you haven't been practicing so
you got a bag full of them broke dude
that thing is gonna [ __ ] hit nothing
you're probably gonna cut your hand but
ladies we got it I mean cat won't you do
an all-call for the ladies because chin
submitted that's crazy man you wrote
your own GART Brooke wrote is music that
[ __ ] is purify huh maybe cash let's see
it ya know you you like Kesha Jin no see
this is the front it says drugged-out
small pinky - I don't know she's better
now she's better now but you only get so
better you know some being a little
thick
yeah she's better know better now dude
dang dude we're trying to get young
gravy to let us chat about one of it we
y'all got to reach out to young gravy
and tell him to come on King in the
sting I wish you'd let us use this song
yeah he might as an intro come on yeah
young gravy got a little thick yeah
rabies this is my move now you gotta
have a better move in this do stuff in
my face
do what about this one broke what's
that's making on what's that at you he
eating a muffin too much work well with
a little butter though do that shut down
the dance it's too stiff dude it's to
stay like other guy eating an invisible
muffin this guy pretending eat muffins
on the dance floor and he's definitely
too thick chinder oh wow I'm young and
gender
bro he's got that rose is that a
traditional Asian like if you bring
flowers is that a traditional thing okay
uh yeah flower sometimes fruits or like
like uh where they caught like a dowry
dowry right yeah
a lot of Asian countries do that
Vietnamese people do that when people
get married instead of a dowry you
basically buy the wife in exchange for
like fruits damn I would just like know
what mangoes return about well
Vietnamese fruits so yeah like what
hmm what kind of fruit we talked ah it's
nice stuff pears but your creator you
ever had a Korean pear huh
yeah Korean pear you don't know if
that's a real thing eh I promise I love
Korean pears really yeah they're fat I
like Oh pears a lot of hotties out there
Korean pears yeah the sake bro it's
right there the Asian pear dude I get my
[ __ ] from Koreatown they each come
individually wrapped oh that third one
yeah right there individually wrapped
ooh [ __ ] special dude Brendan knows
what's up it's almost like an apple but
it's like a pear mm-hmm it's a Bandhan
they're so nice [ __ ] friends are
they're beautiful what is that little
jacket that they're in yeah it's like
they're each individually snuggled up in
these little like almost kind of
stockings yeah dude that thing looks
like it actual Roman hey they're wet bro
you by doing that thing [ __ ] so juicy
why I'll bring I'll bring some I'll
bring dude relax I don't I'm still
eating the subject I'm not moving rabies
be cool dude I'll bring a song my bad yo
rabies yeah
oh lordy time to get you something boy
boy Oh child well you can get anything
you want now I kind of got your own
personal assistant really what you need
oh I want something good that sticky bun
in the afternoon huh hot cocoa at night
you got all that going on right you need
a new deodorant I think dude you want
that Cinnabon and your freaking mouth
piece take three pm do start you some
postmates throw those weights your
personal food delivery notes read Larry
whatever kind of delivery service all
year round 365 days a year 24/7 yeah
your little nephew won't shut up throw a
falafel in that little bad
yeah a dog wherever you add no more
trips of the store no more trips to the
story you still going to the store
what is it 1910 ah post Knights will
deliver anything dude
anything download the app on your phone
yep browse local restaurants businesses
track your delivery in real time
everything you need think about
something
now think about having it fast bozos
ways yes that middleman it's like having
a genie but you have way more than three
wishes it was time man post mates giving
you guys $100 a free delivery credit for
your first seven days $100 dog to start
your free deliveries download the app
use the code cats 2019 love love love
yourself get that oh man I don't even
know what time it is anymore
I don't either dude but if I'd wanted to
I bet those away there is a way and you
can look pretty cool doing it you know I
dude we're giving gifts around here
we're doing the white elephant oh yeah
we are doing that doing white elephant
now this is in castle more than $20 this
one cost $95 I'm talking about the best
watches money can buy I'm talking about
movement bro yep if you're late for
stuff for you sometimes you don't even
show up if you don't show up at all then
you need a calendar but if you're just
late you need a watch watch yourself
show up on time now once you get one man
and you know who's got them movement dad
now you almost forgot the name whoever
watches that just nine minutes and lien
design I'm talking quality watches man
movement has sold over 2 million watches
in over 160 countries worldwide think
about that everywhere you go people know
what time it is and are showing up on
time for things that are above value in
their life dude thing about Christmas
your buddy opens his gift it's a
movement watch come best friend it's
your best that's your bestie brother bro
get 15% off today with free shipping
free returns by going to movement calm
slash Kate 80s that's right get 15% off
today and free shipping free return let
me I see this my hold on like this MVM
t-dot-com / k 80s I got excited let me
ask this what happens if you know maybe
me I need a little bit I want to buy it
now but I want
later bro they had that option on
movement that's the thing if you want to
get somebody a Christmas gift that you
care about or even that you don't even
care about but that's late for things
and needs a watch movement offers buy
now pay later with clarinha payments and
pay overtime for easy payments no fees
yep select clarinha at checkout and you
can pay later and get your watch now go
to nvm t.com / k 80s yes take care of
yourselves and get a nice watch what
about our rafts what about our reps do
we do people submit wraps oh people
submitted ratstar
anything good huh I don't need Canon an
M & M we're going at it so maybe if
these are good yeah Wow the winner
should get that Jack a couple senior
citizens go Jack again that Hall of Fame
of heaven baby bro
Brennan looks like a librarian who knows
how to work the large catalog he looks
flammable brother dude yeah that Roger
comes out dude I'm like holy [ __ ]
Brendan was ahead of the curve and
everyone's rocking this [ __ ] did you see
the boys in Crenshaw this [ __ ] on him
like [ __ ] Brennan start that trend dude
is it out no it drops in December end of
December on Christmas do you see D oh no
I just I saw I mean I know see every
movie is it came out this week though
yeah came out money came by last week
last week yeah Brynn is one of those
guys that doesn't know that it's just
I'm sorry it came out - Oh November 22nd
well it's beautiful day and they read I
had a lot of buzz about it won't you be
my neighbor won't you be my neighbor no
we're gonna be movin I'll be on Zillow
oh I'm gonna order the uber and Qin's
gonna show up and drive me away
Nick how is it in there Nick's holding
the studio down and you're good you know
his Energy's out of the energy levels
out of this world we lock did you drink
a bunch of mound you can read please
calm down
they're probably showing the Midwest he
had two glasses of milk this morning
dude
oh yeah no bro oatmeal cookie uh how are
the wraps no D we got him and he did
people send video expensive videos you
want to say please all right now first a
boy Adam Martin what up yo what up shop
got a debate club for y'all who's more
likely to go and bust a nut Derek's mom
what up can't wait that boy chain can
use the slack can't wait to YouTube dumb
[ __ ] rap gang blankie our place
has been bars and I'm alright now
relationship advice culture corner got
the rice it don't matter wonderful
biggest thing to what it does you guys
are the best
[Applause]
finish with the flag in the back dude
hell yeah Kelly
yeah dude Wow
that's gangster let's hear okay listen
we'll run through that one more time we
call ching ching keys like you haven't
thought about that he didn't say
TRL Wow dude we gotta buy that guy a
llama bro that guy seemed like you would
love Allah more love anything some a
fresh llama dude Wow where was that from
Oregon gang the Ducks beautiful place I
went to I went to a hamster hamster
breeding facility up there when I was
last year you know what tonight get down
up there did you
yeah it's Oregon though you know
anything's possible in Oregon man do
whoever you want
yep what else we got we do this do them
in this is Austin Pollard me tough to
beat that one yeah nobody has a rap name
which is weird they're all given we'll
give them rap
let me hear oh he looks like he has
beads that's a little browse bro
browse up hoes down down little brow get
them caterpillar eyes
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] a little scramble you got
to apologize this guy you win it's our
[ __ ] signal pay a lot of money look
that's not clowning those really little
brows great do on little thick
what's up dude maybe the first guy sign
- ah Oh records I'm a tow-truck death
row dude with a little more death a lot
more row dude that guy was [ __ ] crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude I feel like this would be our theme
song Oh dog it's a rap battle he won
yeah it's hard to get on that train with
you dog it's so good I know
Wow dude damn that was good
bar Lulu you brother did it some Boris
man little brows gang that's a
compliment to hell yeah dude
Google Netscape that's that guy's got it
all do believe you searching for your
[ __ ] feelings those are some good
lyrics man we got one more video for
this guy it's mean tough to be he's
gotta be tough to be that one here we go
we should play out when the end of every
king of the sting this is our boy
decadent nature up next Oh our boy this
sounds like an escort
this also sound like an expensive
chocolate yeah awesome we have another
name little Matt how about we just
shorten everything a little Matt put on
that little net little match
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Brown is still a breakdown Oh burn the
place down the best podcast I have a fan
[Music]
[Music]
wake up well is heaven dude these people
showed out do you need any breakfast I
just realized sorry I didn't mean to
change the subject Club bro we're taking
over Cole - Cole - dude I don't think we
can handle the free world bro now we
can't handle it dude if they keep
sending them hottest tracks wow man I
feel like we got to do something for
these people that sent those tracks it
strikes a pretty dope man
dude that's little brows I think we need
to plant to the end for the rest of the
month at the end of the episodes oh yeah
maybe we can just put different one in
or we could put a different one in four
different episodes yes it was dope it's
hard
yes sir he's released that as a goddamn
well curse the Lord Brendon it's so good
I say god damn you could say that gah t
damn got damn Vietnamese isn't it yeah
get them look damn that's cool well
shoutout to those guys man hell yeah
unbelieving live let's give a run
opposed to knit man or help me put this
together holder corner how did you feel
have your own Mike cat oh it's amazing
I mean now I don't have to feel like I'm
holding it with both like this just
looks inappropriate when we're switching
between Derrick and I yeah we have a lot
of people have screengrab that part of
the episode a lot of people like that
I know people would be pretty
disappointed that you guys aren't Shane
- Mike yeah someone asked if you could
make your hands smaller cat as well I
also asked for bigger mics
so say can you please get those big long
naughty Mike's I didn't know anyone can
get them short thick my welcome to the
court case in the sting you're going to
jail really dude dude we don't we find a
woman for chin I can't remember why you
second I felt like dr. Dre man like
we're discovering new talent first of
all David Duke is getting too old to
text actually cause he's still a human
being he had a couple of tough years man
so there weren't a lot of local groups
to meet up with others who's back before
they had puck in every you know
everybody's having a blast
do you ever read those yelp reviews on
his crew cause Klain yelp review notice
bro
no parking service for a have you shoot
well that's like klu klux klan z7c food
restaurant call Ku Klux Klan was a
robbery in like 1996 whoo I will say
this rug good shower talk the only thing
I'll say I don't have clams inland I'll
need clams real far inland but I got
about a 20 mile
I'll do 20 miles inland I'll do a climb
bro but no Midwest yeah okay they drag
you get oysters in Kansas City that [ __ ]
out my face bro yeah dude I was
somewhere I was in uh in Columbia
Missouri Karp one of those on the wall
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
CBS scare virgos every one of the first
things ever to scare a burglar was one
of those things do you make a
motion-activated yeah those things are
still good oh yeah I'm exhausted man is
that the show yeah what do we do you
guys think of the rappers dude I like
the men browse caterpillar eyes which is
great album title those are the three
best how are the others cuz when raps
bad it's it was my day
it was my day bro just watching you guys
try your hardest I know thank you it's
all about effort man was there a lot of
when they came in yeah oh yeah
everybody's a rapper no no black guys no
black guys wow really
we didn't ask for but if you're out
there cinnamon fellas but I think like
at a certain point I wonder I wonder if
it's do we get into you like um Mexican
guys - no it was all white Wars damn
but we didn't ask for white rappers this
is my thing
a bunch of white guys sent in raps but
not one girl went after chin
they haven't seen the earring yet what
is it about Jim that keeps him away from
women do you feel like mmm I think
there's a lot I'm not quite sure where
to start I think he's very picky
doctor's appointment this jacket make my
neck look short kinda no you're gonna
kind of damn I felt like it did look
it's not a bad look well sound that
great though okay it sounds like it I
don't know what to hit Virginia he's so
picky he's so picky gonna be some dying
peacefully yeah and you'll find
something wrong with their elbows he's
very very picky and you can't yeah a lot
of it's impossible dude you can get
trouble sharpen - there's a girl on
YouTube they can open her envelope with
an elbow up and mail or do like a male
opening hmm I don't know what you do I
don't know talk about a mail-order bride
though huh bad yet I'll do a Russian Oh
to get chin yeah I think he'll come
around when he's ready I think he's
gonna have to really want to but he's
gonna have to start to realize at a
certain age we realize either you know
I'm gonna be that nothing's gonna change
unless I do something different
you know because for a while we're like
Oh some lady will come by you know I'll
walk past like a tall castle and some
lady will be trapped in it or something
like you have these crazy ideas when
you're young you know and then you get
older you're like oh man I don't even I
live in a shitty neighborhood did they
kiss a girl
there's no caption no next one out date
and he's been hot [ __ ] yeah you've been
hot
yeah chin I don't know I don't know I
don't know where to begin it's such a
long story with him that's a lot it's a
lot and it goes back sometime is
generational dwell chin - about dude you
don't mean I just like to work with now
I get it dude you're only here a few
hours
yeah for singing tunes what are you
doing at night what if you can't
yeah what about when you close your eyes
at night who's there with you nobody
[Music]
makes fun
[Laughter]
hell yeah dude you're an [ __ ] okay I
do I look like ah I thought you're
trying to make us look like the movie
twins
I look like Iron Man needs a tetanus
shot I look like the Jolly Green gigolo
Iron Man suit got rabies you're a real
dick but dude I don't look good Thank
You Kat for telling me I'm gonna take
this off just relax a little
yeah I'm trying to get out of my
fighting weight look man this is easy
for me bro but look if you want to make
you look through paperwork or whatever
like you can bring it I love British
look April that have the words on
paperwork we can't have on the screen
yeah we can we can we look like dorks
but I think it brings us closer together
man
yeah you might be right and nothing's
closer together than a pair of socks bro
you ever worn a pair your friends warm
socks that's living brother especially
if their stance if their stance and you
wear them then I put them on do you talk
bro I'm a fungus called me a unicorn at
that point dude I'll pull a unicorn out
of my butt
Stan's socks are fun in oh they're so
good man look I've been look I'll be
I'll be honest I've been rocking stance
for almost probably five years now me
too dude I got him I got the I got the
pairs of black and white pairs see I got
the ones that had the least of these
bandana ones the MBA was they went
through all of that and it'll be I got
the Snoop Dogg when the Star Wars I just
got a pair of Saints Stan's socks my boy
Daniel Ricciardo f1 drivers sent me his
the honey badgers
really dope - never heard of them do the
only
honey badger I know is Walter Matthau
bro sorry ty ran mock down yeah played
at LSU
whatever man go Tigers listen get you
Stan's socks right now official field
sock of the MLB on my dock bro bro quit
wearing dirty stuff on your feet
people wrapping leaves around their feet
dude some people my brother when I was
young we used to fart on my hands and we
call it air mittens abroad when it was
real cold out so that's fair it's not
touching the warm bread listen you guys
here a free pair of socks with your next
order all you have to do is go to Stan's
comm /k ATS that stance tom /k 80s yep
what a great gift gives you got me this
huh
forgot me this may I be stumped don't
you you will not be stoked in but I will
tell you this I did just get my brother
the Grateful Dead set off of there he's
a Deadhead he's the tattoo of Jerry
Lewis or whatever on his chest John
about the ice cream Jerry Garcia yeah
Jerry Garcia
sorry type of ice cream yeah uh he has
it on his chest and well that's cool
yeah but anyway I just got him those
socks they got a good the office you
like the office socks you cut iron
mother I'm rambling but if you um like
that Dunder Mifflin hitters as Pam and
jam yeah dude go Stan stock on such ads
how about your family's tattoos [ __ ] it
it's only bro I'm so [ __ ] lonely man
[Laughter]
we're all naturally kind of bread at the
top you'll never see our traps
you know Candace
[Music]
with a jerry garcia - [ __ ] no no lien
here I robbed their [ __ ] saviors dude
he's comfortable looking that's his body
type
all right guys we got to keep the ad
going look and this is something that I
use regularly you have to especially
during the holidays to get through a
word and if anybody should know about
that
right you learn Lee honey is a free
browser extension that automatically
finds the breast promo codes for you to
shop online
so we're online this holiday season
honey's there to save you yup so look
the other day I'm on nfl.com I'm buying
some stuff right getting a couple of
items a couple of Christmas gifts and uh
next thing you know I get to the
checkout I don't have a code
I hit honey boom boom boom so say 35
bucks dang man Amazon eBay j.crew
Sephora Expedia Target Best Buy and so
many more Vietnam Shanghai Russia
malaysia russia south africa south
african honey has found it's over 10
million members over a billion dollars
in savings that's insane and there's
nothing for you to buy you go to it's
free yes free join honey dot-com slash
cats that's it you go to hom ey come
slash cats and you download this browser
attachment it attaches to Google Chrome
nothing changes or looks any different
on your screen but when you're going to
check out for any item too easy you
click on honey and it'll say hey saving
money hey - easy that's too easy be
honey
it's sweet let's go Brendon whatever how
about that new segment boys the name
game you guys are for sure first this is
Andrew stone it's big Andrew oh we've
got it was something hit from him before
every I think so
you know what up I got one for the new
hitter the name game
who can name more nocturnal animals let
me know name gang buzz you go I go
okay that's one sex week all right so we
can know you know what y'all see him
okay well he's gonna know that I was go
back and forth okay alright Batman
that's a human bat that works okay Wow
owl is good worm moles moles what moles
mo le I'm all okay okay okay when I keep
going in the fact checked out [ __ ]
yeah and my side right Derek if you're
responsible writing it down derek has a
computer from he's writing on his phone
that's very strange
my turn nighttime animal I'm gonna go
with a trustee out of my deal oh god I
don't know if they are a nighttime
animal do they stay up at night see just
Google armadillo images see if there's
any pictures of just darkness around
them in their eyes lit up
alright then I'll go while they're
looking I'm gonna say a shark animal bro
they can't stop they can't stop they
will stop all night bro are they really
nice that's how they breathe do sharks
get rest at night we Google that dare
don't sleep swimming non-stop so that's
not turtle suck do sharks sleep Derek's
checking right now sharks do not sleep
when sets have two active restful so
they go you know I'm saying
wow I could just type in nocturnal
animals guys we didn't want to see them
all yeah Brett is still running on
[ __ ] Netscape your head okay I'll go
with a nocturnal animal and I'm gonna
treat you guys to a very
special animal right now and this
wonderful animal that a lot of people
aren't even familiar with is called a
lightning bug is its street name
lightning bug all right
- this one Theo's mom probably grills
them up on the weekends that little
possum thank you dude they are not tasty
though it's all fat bro and some of the
some of the meat is just brown fat yeah
you're like what is this dude it's just
me okay nocturnal animal I'm gonna go
with an animal that a lot of people
don't even really often chat about or
talk with other people about because
they're afraid spider
I feel like we're just naming animals
all spiders are nocturnal I'm hit you
with that burglar of the rainforest that
[ __ ] raccoon dude
wreck who's always get caught - like
they're always like okay nocturnal
animal let me think about one that's
very nocturnal please do okay an animal
you'll see at night if you're outside at
night yes yep and you are say you're
wandering around and you think oh what
is that an animal and that animal
it is no I'm not doing it Rottweiler
[Laughter]
look it up Derek Rottweilers at night
Derek if you're not a spell Rottweiler
you just lost your urban card Trojan
horse dude [ __ ] come on dude all the
things he helped my Rottweiler won't
sleep Rottweiler at night she cries a
lot at night and that's what I would
hear let's go to Derek what do you guys
have nocturnal animals hmm is a court
took that submission by the way mmm
actually that was amazing Nick you got
any I feel like we did all right good
what's the last I need to come up with
that it's hard to think about what
animals are out there any night coyotes
nocturnal then little [ __ ] be how
yeah they know do they really damn high
I don't have that kind of money where I
have coyote problems okay yeah your bums
Alan this only yeah you have to be like
a brand-new American Mexican person if
coyote issues or a wealthy [ __ ]
person if hey I like those kangaroos
like oh those rules but they sleep a lot
of things you have internal are they
really you know what is funny times when
I think about him I do think about him
like being up at night so really cool
that [ __ ] honey spill
Lana will read to impel that pellet I'm
right you [ __ ]
Britta don't think I have that sweats
and then dips of bread in it little
thick rope little thick tons cardio
bunny damn shallow heart in this how we
got ups and I beat us today's class like
[Laughter]
I'm trying to catfish these homeless
whoa a little cute like girl a fake-ass
time on that bike that's my biggest
little thick hose what's up 300 classes
correct boy Ali love knows what's up I
take a class of morning New York classes
also thought
don't let that commercial get you down
these hoes can't hold it down I know
stocks a little low we coming back I got
you bro yeah I'll get you one for
Christmas you all right man what the
[ __ ] Derrick run the show or I have
awesome debate club
first this is Justin I've had so much
mother [ __ ] tired
hey the white rappers exhausted me they
were so good so [ __ ] good experience
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
dude and I'm Ellen Ellen degenerate I'm
gonna dance lot of commercials on duty
well how about this though the best
nocturnal animal nobody named the white
rapper you know they're up all night
making beats ah dude also something we
forgot nocturnal serial killer only the
night Jeffrey Dahmer nocturnal do we
need a brave ass hirako that's willing
to kill her in the daytime that's the
next thing that might be Trin daylight
say yeah hell yeah dog [ __ ]
I could see chin have a nice killer yeah
that lunch killer yeah that afternoon
killer the brooch murderer that traffic
jam killer
oh it's bumper-to-bumper do they say the
face you make when you're dying is the
face you have in heaven dude how crazy
is that
all bats if you get stabbed yeah you got
a little confident it haha when you die
dude like even if you burn to death you
better be like where did toe broaches oh
yeah did you want to work at this zoo
that I'm like an almost win it on
not invested just but as long as you
guys had a bald eagle I'm in dude oh
they got [ __ ] Eagles down there man
they got a lot of [ __ ] illegal Birds
down there but they said what they
needed bouncers I'm like it's a they're
like but we wanna serve liquor drink
specials oh yeah
they said we need a liquor license of I
guess Mexico dude that's the liquor
license you can drink man you can enjoy
yourself
give these ostriches tequila man yeah
just random [ __ ] many [ __ ] flamingos
bro one of them has a knife sorry huh
let's talk about Bobby Lee yesterday so
every now and then he comes out of me
hey what do you got we got our boy
Justin from SD Justin from San Diego
hello there hello Brendan this is Justin
from San Diego and I have a debate club
for you guys today
beautiful tea I grew up listening to
classic rock and I still do listen to
classic rock quite a bit and I want to
know what do you guys like better the
Rolling Stones
or the Beatles it's the age-old question
I personally have to go with the Rolling
Stones but I want to know what you guys
think
stones gang beetle buzz let's hear it
buzz it's a good question it is it's
kind of like what do you prefer the
whole [ __ ] band the boys with a
[ __ ] you're cut remember they all
have the [ __ ] the monkeys they all
look the same
was that the monkeys Beatles did oh yeah
do the same thing to John Legend John
Lennon right dark Beatle that dark the
dark is beetle Rome Oh
so back is rolling stones or the center
delizia Mick Jagger right yeah that
dudes bodied yeah he looks like yeah he
looks like a Steven Tyler if you like
hung his head
window for a long time voice moving car
to moving at heart no these guys are
legend goes that hits Rolling Stones
handsome yes give me give me one other
bang look at that guy right there
Hundley you know is that all I got
shredded that's the old Harry Styles
brother dudes a legend yeah you're right
I'm more of a Rolling Stones man yeah
what's the other thing
now the Beatles you knew more of them
like I can't tell you who else is in the
Rolling Stones man it's Mick Jagger and
then after that dude it's all marbles
yeah yeah the Beatles is high right I
have no clue for the Beatles who it's
John Legend god damn it John Lennon who
else Paul McCartney I'm off a plane
ghosts are Incan beads Ringo just on the
keyboard wouldn't he yeah he kind of he
kind of look like a muppet gently but as
far as like Tunes dude dude hold on we
can't not name all four Beatles bro or
we're gonna [ __ ] lose it do you have
for Don Lemon Paul McCartney Ringo Starr
who's that fourth who's you guy that got
murdered by his wife that's the art you
think that George but who's the fourth
Beatle Chris Benoit yeah that's a
wrestler Benny I know he killed his life
think to themselves oh you know it was
speaking your Tennessee Titans hat go
Titans dude Steve McNair Steve in there
good call
the fourth Beatle me I've been recruit
know everybody every time somebody shoot
somebody or has an abortion they blame
it on Rae Carruth dude so sick of that I
can't I still get the four I know you
can't bro you know I've known you for
years man whatever it is you can't um
the fourth Beatle
yeah dude you think I'm a freaking the
delinquent yeah I do really even after I
took off that jacket with this fresh
eyes met bro his Fagin it has a chance
though I want you and Peter Dinklage to
have a head-butting contest hold on the
fourth Beatle is I know it it's Ringo
it's Paul it's Daniel no John John Paul
Ringo and right there
John Paul Ringo and Alan uh it's a man
talk about Todd Snider no it's not hah
think about the letters the outfit go to
that it start with an A no B no C no no
Harry no what's this the last thing your
clothes Harry's the last thing your
clothes with that Barry it's not very
what is it
yo truth you said truth is a black guy
George George George what Harrison
George Harrison you idiot ever heard of
yeah I've never heard of that man George
you never heard of George George Harris
was still alive no I've heard of him a
thousand times you do bro McCarney won't
[ __ ] leave us alone he's killing it
though I know dude he's them he's like
the male Betty White Betty White died
too no yeah did she
two weeks ago [ __ ] no she didn't [ __ ]
you she did really yeah damned Wafaa
it's like I've been trapped in this
bubble dude they tell me Betty White
dead you can just put Betty White she's
alone she's alive dude you tell me Betty
White died and and mr. Rogers came out
Betty White's alive mr. Rogers came out
alright a lot of people said she was
dead when I was young man when I was a
kid they had field trips and stuff and
one time we went on this um like two-day
field trip or two night and I told
everybody before we went I was like
it was camping and I was like oh Jay
Leno died and everybody was [ __ ] like
no way yeah nobody knew cuz there was no
way to like get information no
cellphones yeah so people were talking
about and said never you kidding piss
when you got back huh the kids the
parents were all of the parents are the
ones that were like just like waited at
the rumor what a weird kid why would he
say that it's believable we go I like
cuz I'm an artist you freak we got 55%
went with the Beatles Wow on that one
yeah up next we got our boy mr. I like
Queen better than both of them whatever
that says about me this is like Queens
right Marcus and Kobe okay
[Music]
oh you gotta wah wah
we've seen a lot of relatives I'm pretty
sure
questions that you feel have you ever
been to Nicaragua
it's nice death let's check it out
walking on the beaches on a flat spot
it's so guys we've got a debate glove
chocolate for you the two main things to
do here or heighten volcanoes like this
one or surf on the coast and so debate
club which one's better Gang Gang
[Music]
yeah well y'all just got done doing well
they're enjoying and in the cell I know
they are man something you should do
good dude is this you know DVD oh
there's of Captain Phillips huh we're
the [ __ ] Somali pirates you think
they're on a yacht they're out surf and
it relax and they're enjoying their time
okay not everybody likes [ __ ] robbing
sea of Piccadilly [ __ ] diners at 4
p.m. in the afternoon bowels that make
it difficult you're the one who began
spent three years in first grade so well
the second is a lot of senior citizens
are cold today because most your sins
are super jelly when they watch King in
the sting but they can't hack and snack
and shut your trap they can't really do
like a bite if I send to you to take a
like medication a walk of mine take all
your medicine all right these little
thirst cats want to know volcanoes or
surface I've never been in a coda and
Nick got our but I hope to go one day
he's not that was Hawaii Maui fellas
that's cool
dude I'm with a water bra don't make me
put this jacket back on please don't
okay well people just died on hiking
volcano see that yeah they're like oh
let's check out the volcano what do
volcanoes do they explode bro not gonna
happen
they have no idea what's gonna happen so
all those people died I forget where
they're hiking
I think it's New Zealand just pop your
hot dog dude it's Mother Nature surprise
party baby you know what I'm saying
that's nature busting bro it's ovulation
baby
yeah that's lava elation it's milk from
the LA blood yeah presto if you're
walking on somebody's chair dude knit
bus murders far apart of it she's on you
bro
that's why you can see far because you
want to some time you need to see things
from far away you know and then surfing
I don't know what kind of sharks in the
waters out there area you'll be fine
dude I think you just got a if you see a
shark get out you know and plus dude
long you're not surfing at night you
liar then you'll be fine dude here's the
other I'm thick I look like a seal so
sharks like let's eat that do look like
an Easter seal telethon day like a
straight fundraiser bro dude
I guess what these guys just hiked with
your bro and that's fine what do you
mean I'm saying that be fun dude what is
it
yeah their outdoor champions are young
men that are venturing out and learning
about themselves and having the courage
to to see dude I think they're gonna get
their [ __ ] degree semester at sea
just like you did dude look I think
these guys will be fine wear a sunscreen
you know and don't pretend each other's
a woman that's my rule but see it's
weird dude the boat starts rocking your
visions all crazy oh yeah I know your
buddy dude
chest muscles are just strong ass tits
bro you feel me dude what are these guys
hiking hiking or what surfing I actually
like to surf but nobody thinks you ain't
never been served
bro I bid that body this is surfers body
no that's a boogie board I did hurt my
neck yesterday looking at some yeah
wonderful
thing at this point with the chance
these guys they've gotten missing by now
when was this video submitted hopefully
they're alive let make sure they follow
up with this man hopefully made to the
top of the mountain they'll say
hopefully made thought mountain ripped
shirt yeah I think whoever gets to the
top of the mountain dude wrestles the
other yeah yeah but the other one
doesn't get to use any wrestling moves
for like 30 seconds yeah what people say
fifty five percent with volcano yeah
that one yeah and I go volcano to T and
I ain't afraid to [ __ ] get up there
and sip straight off the tip of the
[ __ ] Dark Lord's hell yeah all right
guys one last one one last King under
sting and that's it blood Sugar's low
I'll probably be fine dude if I don't
look like I'm awake I'm not that's cool
dude start crippling our boy Jerry Jerry
using any excuse if you're if you're
just listening on the video then Jerry
took a as much sour cream as you could
fit onto a large spoon and put it on to
a folded up pizza crust and then here's
the best part
brought it up to his mouth and just ate
the sour cream off the tray he was a
sundae with whipped cream didn't even
eat in here the down no shell shut no
shell whatsoever bro hey filling broke
okay oh I like this guy's vibe I love
sour cream especially dude if you go to
talk about you gotta get the supreme
with a side
do you my rapper you gotta get the
supreme with the little Jerry now will
respect this he is down obviously just
omission if she is eating sour cream
light you can see on the side of the jug
it does say light so I'll respect that
Jerry obviously a hard worker he looks
like he a mechanic bleeding eating lunch
with his hands that have grease on them
which I also appreciate I do too yeah do
you get if something's too dry you just
[ __ ] suck whatever you know grease it
up baby just suck whatever is left in
your thumb saw in the little dimples
[ __ ] wrinkles on your knuckles yeah
like Oh or just spray up [ __ ] hit a
wd-40 on that dry crusty some brake
fluid on that baby oh yeah steak fluid
dude sour cream straight to the dome off
a pizza crust
I gotta respect that days I'm a fan bro
that's a new national anthem dude yea
that's living baby it really is almost
the new national anthem just eating a
bunch of sour cream off of a pizza crust
bro
it's American for apple pie baby and
that traps how sour cream like that guy
dude [ __ ] God dude I'm exhausted
with how much amazing Broadway play
people stopped plated people sit in man
thank you so much way to kick off the
new studio man yeah it's a good way man
the people really make the show don't
they take a point put any dummies here
man oh yes but sex I'm not but sex
that'll be my joke dude I'll be both
sites for like a month but that's it as
long as my judge is okay with it did he
make it
oh yeah he made it all [ __ ] you know
what's my neck was longer yeah me too
men for you my next one that is for you
I don't read her a much neck
nobody's look to you my god that guy's
got a real knack on well I'm not your
friend long yeah I'm somewhere between
you long neck and Peter Dinklage which
means I'm pretty normal
liddie like a titty boy that's all I'm
saying dude what else do people need to
know Derrick and okay we are any new
submissions are we doing
no yeah submit the cat we'll post uh I'm
not for the chance that we hit so many
yeah for chin we got to do some chin
chin Durr chinder up hoes down and then
we'll be posting some new segments as
well videos from me and Theo
um this drops this week huh yeah Oh
Christmas videos yes everyone saying
Christmas videos worst gift best gift
family traditions to me a Christmas
themed episode I see Christmas we up and
we're gonna do white elephant here in
the studio what's what else so it is and
don't get scared Derrick okay um it is
no it's not a racist thing I know I saw
that and that's why I said that it is
just a gift thing where you give
somebody they mix up what is it Nick run
well what's half of us Cobra is not the
worst food of all fun that she talked
about is like a 70 second lifespan right
people right when T dollars or less is
the rule and then we are mixed them up
yeah we pull names out of a brand to get
ahead that's easy
yeah I'm an Atlantic City dude Borgata
casino Wow one night once your only man
it's gonna be fine it's a big boy move
for me I'm excited by Diamond you were
just there la jolla next week Comedy
Store yeah I was just there dude Joe
Musgrove came out shot out man
Pittsburgh pirate isn't a great [ __ ]
we brought out a couple of his ear
buddies too and I feel bad I don't
remember the names I just met him
briefly but I catch nope your loss
and then Derek's headline is first show
on Sunday because I'm due Sunday's yeah
Sunday la jolla coming thank you big
brown ticket $10 come on out Sunday
please
first I'm headlining it's for your boy
Emily oh yeah open an hour bro so if you
like we would Brendon I'll be there that
weekend if you like me come out Sunday
Thursday Friday Saturday he's doing
Sunday
oh man I'd only go in after Derek man I
will say it
love you feel wise Brady you do that I
know that's my line I have a show coming
up in everyone in LA right Toronto
Brendon different
oh I've one in LA tonight at The Wiltern
but that's gonna be done tonight I
didn't know that brother that's a good
night yeah oh wow
so should be pretty fun but yeah I got
some in Toronto and uh
Oroville California you go there that
Oracle casino yeah that's dope it is yes
I'm excited about that so Oroville
toronto and I think that's it I'm coming
to Europe in January so pretty fired up
and I'm gonna do another lawyer show I
don't know when it'll be though but
it'll probably be right in between
Christmas and New Year's don't man so
get your tickets go see deal yeah thank
you guys so much for all the submissions
man this is great everybody made some
nice stuff and sent it in you guys make
the show make the show yeah and I think
this is a good reminder of that Thank
You Kat Thank You Derek Gang Gang
Brendon a deal fighter and Creole
shout-out New Orleans a shout-out to Co
Colorado more specifically Boulder
Brendan came in with the chip on his
shoulder but is still gold and get is
still fire if you don't like King in
this thing you're a liar
Brendan's got like a thousand different
hustles one of them's at Nordstrom Rack
to untie yours black rifle [ __ ] we hear
you loud and clear your son on the email
like please get me out of here it's way
too loud in here watching the Irishman
eating pizza drinking half a beer now on
to Theo von look I like the type of dude
- Rita song smoking cigarettes with a
snapback on not to hit the crib and turn
snapchat on it's all good we still mess
with 1800 Pico Boulevard Oh get that hit
Deborah can cat y'all doing great
Thursday upload not a minute late y'all
wanted a rap I had a demonstrate brand
new studio y'all feelin great putting
Chris Delano in his place now let's go
and get Jenna date